[Music]
dude what dude what
hey youtubers is Charlie welcome to the
guardians of the frickin galaxy we got
new footage I totally love scenes like
this this is really indicative of how
things get so crazy in the Marvel
Universe yet they keep the story
relatively self-contained and human so
you can understand that these are just
people trying to form a family together
even nebula there is going crazy so
there's a new round of the Marvel
giveaway I'm giving away those Hasbro
spider-man figures all you have to do to
enter is be a subscriber and leave a
comment on this video so I'll announce a
winner when I post that trailer video
tomorrow but after they released the
first trailer James Gunn went on and on
about how they let Drax and dave
bautista
be so much funnier in this movie it's
the same way people are talking about
Chris Hemsworth in Thor Ragnarok like
he's a very funny person in real life
let him be funny in the movie within the
scope of the character some of the Drax
lines in the first guardians film got
some of the biggest laughs when I was in
the movie theater watching it for the
first time she betrayed Ronan he's
coming back for her and when he does
that's what
oh no symbol this is a symbol for you
slicing his throat claim to general
expression for you killing somebody
you've heard of this you've seen this
right you know what that is so a lot of
you were asking for a Groot origin story
because we have baby Groot so I'll sort
of explained the logic behind baby Groot
in comic book Groot because his origin
story has changed a couple times in the
comics he was originally created by Stan
Lee and Jack Kirby in tales to astonish
and he became this nightmare for
spider-man he was really just meant to
be this living tree that talked it was
really scary like oh my god it's another
monster later he became more of a
guardians of the galaxy character got a
more complex backstory and then later
writers even in the more recent run
rewrote that story again to make it a
little less hardcore so in the original
version of events he's just a nightmare
in Peter Parker's head he just has this
crazy dream he shows up during
Incredible Hulk annual number 5 just
very brief appearances the first time he
shows up in the guardians of the galaxy
universe his origin story is that he
basically just doesn't get along with
other people of his kind he's from the
planet X he's flora Colossus any sort of
their version of royalty so he's almost
like star-lord he's this very special
person even amongst his own people but
just a total outcast just does not fit
in with anyone but the Guardians which
is part of what draws him to them so the
part that they change from his backstory
is the reason he left his home planet is
because he was exiled by the other arbor
masters which are basically like they're
ruling council for killing another of
his kind to protect a non flora Colossus
so on their planet that omnipotent they
have genius-level intellect they're
highly evolved species they pass
information along photonic lees through
photosynthesis it's very efficient so
they're these highly evolved creatures
but they have mammals to do lesser jobs
so what happened was is that brutes saw
one of the other flora Colossus abusing
a mammal so he intervened ended up
killing one of his other species so they
banished him and he actually became a
cap
of the collector in the original version
of events so like during the first
guardians film when the collector is
like please allow me the pleasure of
taking your body when you die like he
wants to collect Groot
that was just a bit of a wink at that
then during the guardians of the galaxy
comic the reason that he comes to work
with star-lord is because for unknown
reasons he's a captive of the Kree and
he and Rocket gain their freedom by
joining star Lords guardians of the
galaxy's so they escaped during the
conflict that was during anihilation
conquest so it was the annihilators
trying to destroy the universe with the
help of ultron it was a crazy story that
they didn't really adapt for the movie
but then what happened more recently in
the comics you know because of the
resurgence of the guardians of the
galaxy comics after the movie came out
they sort of rewrote everyone's
backstory a little bit
so groots backstory now the only change
that they made is that the reason he got
banished from Planet X his home planet
is that he realized his race was
abducting people he found someone named
Hannah rescued her and then they
banished him because he broke their laws
so that's really just the minor change
instead of killing one of his own kind
he just went against them so you can see
just a less hardcore version of that
story but the baby Groot twists just to
explain that so in the comics he's
capable of growing himself from pieces
of his own biomatter
just like you would grow a tree that
still had a root system that was intact
so like you know you can trim a tree and
it will still continue to grow so it's
kind of the same thing with Groot he can
reconstitute himself from even a small
piece of his own bio matter so you kind
of see that play out the first time you
meet him during that annihilation
conquest storyline so like this panel
here with mantis she was actually part
of that first Guardians story where you
see her spritzing sapling Groot here
that happened during that very first
Guardians Groot story before that he was
sort of a character that existed by
himself he wasn't always a guardians of
the galaxy character but because of the
way marble is branding itself the way
it's selling toys there are a lot of
questions about whether or not he is
going to stay baby Groot when we get to
infinity war it sounds like he might but
there hasn't been any evidence to show
that he will or he won't so you guys can
let me know because in the comics he is
capable of increasing his mass very
quickly so he can grow any time he wants
but the way Jane
gaeun explains baby Groot in this movie
is that he has no memory from his
previous life so this is like a brand
new version of Groot he said he is dumb
as rocks so when he's being all cute
trying to press the button that's gonna
blow everyone sky-high he's actually
trying his hardest to help to listen to
rocket so it's not like he's playing
dumb he's actually very dumb in this
movie in this moment but very eager to
help so we'll see how long it takes him
to figure out or if he stays this way
when we get to infinity war but either
way let me know what you guys are most
excited about I'll post that trailer
video tomorrow night it'll drop really
late at night so it'll be after my flash
episode video but there'll be some new
DC TV that I'll be posting later today
so it's gonna be a whole bunch of marvel
and DC stuff happening the next couple
days while you wait for that you can
click here for more guardians of the
galaxy and you can click here for brand
new iron fist thank you so much for
watching let's high five I'll see you
guys tonight